hey hey
okay let's do it welcome to the kissing
booth
after spending four years with elle her
best friend lee and her hunky boyfriend
noah their romantic story finally comes
to a close netflix's young adult
franchise reaches its final chapter in
the kissing booth 3 where el tries to
complete a summer bucket list while in
the meantime having to make the ultimate
decision about her future as fans are
swooning over elle and noah's adorable
romance we'll be taking a look behind
the scenes of the final installment of
the streamer's delightful trilogy
here we go
you may be surprised to learn that the
third entry of the kissing booth series
was actually filmed back in 2019 it was
shot back to back with the kissing booth
too making it a much longer shoot than
usual with king saying it was a
bittersweet experience really enjoyed
that moment and appreciated the time i
had with all the lovely cast and crew
and was even kept a secret until several
days after the release of the second
film joel courtney revealed that he had
a difficult time not being able to tell
anybody about the third film claiming it
was the hardest secret to keep it has to
be said that the cast did a great job at
keeping themselves tight-lipped while
doing press for the second film
kissing booth 3 is going to be released
in summer 2021.
joey king actually had to wear a wig on
set of both the kissing booth 2 and 3.
king had recently wrapped filming of the
true crime hulu miniseries the act
opposite patricia arquette and had
shaved her head for the role of gypsy
rose blanchard king revealed on
instagram the extensive process of how
her wig was applied while the
application took some time king said
that it was worth it simply because she
loved playing l the worst thing that
ever happened in the world just kidding
between filming the first film and its
two sequels joey king and her on-screen
boyfriend jacob allordy had started a
real-life romance but ultimately broke
up between the two shoots
this led to it being quite awkward on
set between the pair especially since it
was a lengthier shoot than usual
king emphasized that it wasn't easy
working with a lordy once again but at
the same time she was simply just
thrilled to be playing l evans once
again the former couple didn't share as
much on-screen time together in the
second film though they certainly
accompany each other in plenty of scenes
in the third and final film despite the
heartbreak it does sound like bearing
through the awkwardness was worth it in
the end
would you ever date another actor again
on let you meet in a movie no
since the third film was filmed back to
back with the second this meant that the
shoot was much longer than your typical
shoot star joey king was actually able
to celebrate her 20th birthday on the
set of the third film which must have
been quite the celebration in south
africa
after his breakup with joey king before
filming the sequels jacob allordy needed
someone new to vibe with on set the
friend he found wasn't somebody you'd
expect his name was tim bella and he was
my driver and best friend
according to the heartthrob he actually
formed a bond with his driver we go have
dinner together afterward and we're
always mucking around and stuff
hopefully mr bella was invited to the
premiere
the kissing booth is notably based on a
book series of the same name written by
beth regals
while the first two movies had regal's
books to bounce off of the third film
actually didn't this caused director
vince marcelo and writer jay arnold to
try to figure out what should happen
next in the film version of the series
rico's take on l's ending titled one
last time actually released the same day
as the film on august 11th 2021
this meant fans of the books weren't
able to find out what college elle
decided to go to before everyone else
joey king has said that both the second
and third films were shot simultaneously
and out of order which has led to her
occasionally confusing which scene
belongs to which movie while the final
scene that was shot was actually one for
the second movie king's last scene was
with her on-screen bff joel courtney it
was the scene where joel and i are
having that really heart-to-heart with
him about the collagen honestly we can't
think of a better final scene for the
tuta film especially since it was their
friendship that started it all
let's do it
megan young revealed that she actually
had a morning ritual on set of the
kissing booth sequels by bringing
morning oats for breakfast young's
co-stars took note of her daily
breakfast routine and soon enough stars
like taylor zakar perez and joey king
were bringing their own morning oats to
set
you could say the young was a
trendsetter on set kissing booth was
that experience that like once in a
lifetime kind of experience
jacob allordy has revealed that over the
course of the past three movies there
has been less and less kissing in each
subsequent film
this makes sense as the third
installment is the only film of the
trilogy not to feature the titular
attraction fear not though as elordi
assured fans that there's still plenty
of kissing in the film well that's a
relief
while filming the mario kart sequence in
the third film joey king's mother and
boyfriend were sitting right behind the
camera watching her and joel courtney
face off king revealed that she often
brings the popular nintendo racing game
to various film and television sets and
that she did bring it with her while
filming the kissing booth movies
honestly who wouldn't want to face joey
king off in mario kart what are you
doing
winning
the former queen of teen movies molly
ringwald has of course played the role
of mrs flynn in all three kissing booth
movies much like how elle forms a strong
connection with mrs flynn joey king
formed a friendship with the iconic 80s
star hugging her was just as you would
you'd expect so warm and wonderful king
has stated that getting to hug ringwald
for a scene in the third film was a
definite highlight but as a person i
feel so lucky to have gotten to know her
joey king is clearly living the dream
from getting to meet famous icons like
ringwald as well as getting to kiss not
only jacob allordy but also taylor zakar
perez
regardless of the project jacob allordy
has always been committed to the
characters he plays on screen much like
he did with other roles ilordi wrote a
journal through the eyes of noah in
order to prepare himself for all three
films
maybe lordy will become the next great
method actor alongside leonardo dicaprio
and joaquin phoenix
nice
despite its southern california setting
the kissing booth 3 was actually filmed
in south africa much like the first two
films the cast and crew have revealed
that during filming they've encountered
plenty of situations that wouldn't be
considered normal occurrences in
california
including dealing with monkeys who would
constantly steal things from the set
sounds like trouble
while joey king and jacob belordy's
relationship may not have lasted king
did form a close friendship with joel
courtney
courtney revealed that his chemistry in
bond with king on screen was entirely
effortless comparing it to putting on
your favorite jacket it slips right on
you and you know exactly how to wear it
hopefully we'll get to see king and
courtney starr together in more films
together in the future at least the
press tour gave us a couple more cute
moments between the two hey there i'm
jill courtney and i am joey king
many fans believed that jacob allordy
was miserable on set of the sequels
since he was having to work with his
ex-girlfriend joey king he has gone on
to deny those rumors and claims that he
just has a resting miserable face noah
is already known for being moody so
maybe it's all part of him trying to get
into character
while there may have been some drama
behind the scenes it sure seems like
joey king joel courtney jacob allordy
and the rest of the kissing booth cast
and crew had a great time filming the
sequel
do you have a favorite kissing booth
moment